okay listen I got something wrong with
me that's the first thing to know I
twitch and shout a lot makes me look
like a damn freak show first cut that
out so I touch it Bailey I'm sorry but
inside my heads an even bigger mess I
can't stop twisting things around words
and sounds especially have to keep
playing with them until they come out
right sorry
she's forget I asked like I said a damn
mess then I started working for Frank
Frank men a private eye boys Frank
frankly frankly Frank Oh
he's the one who taught me how to use my
head turn it into his strength he gave
me a place in his crappy world until I
screwed up
[Music]
does anybody know what Frank was into on
this there's something going down and
it's big and they were not happy about
what he found we find who did this we
square it counts
if I figure it out I'm gonna make him
regret it I promise you that that's her
that's the girl that Frank was following
I think she found something what happens
to poor people in this city wasn't news
yesterday and it won't be tomorrow
where's everybody go mostly just
disappear this town is run by Moses
Randolph when someone isn't seen for
what they truly are that's a very
dangerous thing if the first inkling of
power works power is knowing that you
can do whatever you want or not one
person can stop you
those people are invisible they don't
exist if you threaten his work he will
destroy you
you're all alone you got no idea
[Music]
you webbed up in this somehow and these
people aren't gonna stop if you got a
head just like my always turning things
around some people call it a gift but
it's a brain the flesh and just to say
you remember what I said she doesn't
know she doesn't know what don't I know
[Music]
[Music]